gangster ah that's the sound of a good
interview start trouble started with my
eyes when I was sixteen seventeen and by
the time I was 18 I had to stop driving
doctor said you legally blind you got
10600 vision you can't you can't be
behind the wheel and be safe I have
visually impaired ease but legally blind
boy Paxton is the stupidest stage name I
could come up with so I just omitted the
legally I'm Chris funk I'm a musician in
a band called The Decemberists and I'm
on a journey looking for the most
surprising and extraordinary people in
music my next stop takes me to New York
City
there I will meet a virtuoso in his 20s
whose genius is playing music that's 100
years old
[Music]
my name is Gerard Paxton born south
central los angeles currently of new
york city and the world traveler I'm a
music physician dr. feelgood of music as
it was
Geron is a master of forgotten music the
first time I heard him play I thought I
was listening to some old obscure 45s he
can pick up almost any instrument it
sounds like he just stepped off the
Mississippi Delta I play guitar banjo
harmonica piano fiddle and some other
instruments that are reserved for
private pleasure what get your mind out
of the gutter people call this
traditional music and a lot of people
tend to think of me as a revivalist I
don't tend to think of things in those
term because I'm musician this is music
always played and always played it for
my family
it's not old and traditional or
throwback
I'm just a dude that plays music that my
folks and I want to listen to play the
melody with the right side no way and
you play the harmony with the left side
[Laughter]
one of my favorite things about Jurong
is that he's on a historical mission of
sorts rediscovering for the rest of us
the original black music of America
people don't associate the banjo with
black people anymore and you know 200
years ago that's all you associated with
Oh baby that's my direction to find the
music that relates to my culture I had
to go back I had to go back past record
in history I had to go back to the 1840s
to here with that kind of music sound
like and seeing this ain't no records of
it I have to recreate it you know I'm
the one a handful of black banjo players
left in the world I figured to represent
black banjo music all had to do is just
act natural
back home in South Central I played in
music like my grandmother taught me from
the cotton field it don't have too much
European overtones and influences the
techniques and lot of the melodies are
made out of whole cloth by the builders
of America my gangster brother and
sister after watching Geron at the
Jalopy theater in Brooklyn play songs
that are a hundred years old it's easy
to see why he can captivate an audience
it takes me you know it's my music it's
my culture and it's my passion and I
don't watch TV and I don't have too many
other hobbies so this is what I get into
and I get into the history of it it
seems to be more entertaining than any
book in any story you could read because
it's all real and as more of it to be
discovered
[Applause]
you
[Music]